[Musique]
on croirait la ville tout juste soufflé
par une explosion des arbres à terre des
toits envolés témoigne de la puissance
de l'impact en février dernier deux
cyclones bat s'y rallier et mme natty
frappé la côte est laissant derrière eux
une ville exergue et des milliers de
sans abris privés de nourriture et d'eau
parmi eux gîte à 29 ans mère célibataire
de deux enfants
[Musique]
ces distributions de l'état se limite à
un repas par jour un morceau de poulet
du riz et des légumes pour son logement
et les autres repas jta devra se
débrouiller seul
notre maison a déjà subi un incendie
cette fois les complètement détruite
nous n'avons nulle part où aller je
lance un appel au président pour nous
aider face à cette situation le
président malgache s'était déplacé en
personne au lendemain du cyclone bâtira
et des dizaines de millions d'euros de
l'aide internationale ont été injectés
dans des opérations d'urgence mais ici
neil 300 ménages sur 5500 sont toujours
privés de logements
kellock voilà où était notre maison
et là c'est notre toit qui s'est
effondré elle mange désormais par terre
au milieu des décombres même s'il vous
plaît madame vous pouvez me prêter une
cuillère pour que mon enfant puisse
manger il faut que tu la remercie
là mon fils mange mais parfois il n'y a
pas suffisamment de nourriture pour lui
et moi je suis obligé de me priver parce
qu'il a beaucoup d'appétit
ce soir jta ne mangera pas il passera la
nuit à la belle étoile faute de places
disponibles en sites d'hébergement
d'urgence
je rentre la première pour arranger le
lit de mes enfants
je passe par ici je soulève ce à
un bon c'est là que je vais faire le lit
de mes enfants
ici c'est ici que je vais les installer
pour dormir
et demain je partirai de bon matin
chercher un petit boulot et trouver de
quoi nourrir mes petits
se loger se nourrir le cyclone a emporté
avec lui les droits humains fondamentaux
le plus vital d'entre eux l'accès à
l'eau potable les inondations mélanger
les eaux usées aux eau propre une
situation aggravée par la défécation à
l'air libre largement pratiqué dans la
région pour limiter les maladies dues à
la consommation d'eau souillée l'unicef
distribue des kits de purification d'eau
mais surtout incite les habitants à se
défaire des mauvaises habitudes
si nos matières fécales sont éparpillés
dans la nature elles vont infecter l'eau
du canal des pangalanes et seront mangés
par les poissons et où vont ces poissons
après dans vos assiettes n'est ce pas il
est possible que les poissons mangent
vos matières fécales et donc vous
mangerez vos matières fécales vous
aimeriez ça
voilà c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer
les bonnes pratiques c'est à dire
utiliser les toilettes et y mettre les
selles des enfants d'accord
alors que les cas de diarrhée et de
fièvre typhoïde se multiplient les ong
veulent éviter une épidémie à laquelle
l'hôpital public de mananjary ne
pourrait faire face car le cyclone bats
hirai a emporté son toit est abîmé une
bonne partie de ses équipements et
médicaments depuis les accouchements ont
lieu dans ces tentes d'urgence grâce au
matériel installé par des ong
[Musique]
je suis vraiment reconnaissante d'avoir
accouché ici mais ce qui m'attriste
c'est que notre maison a été détruite et
que si nous sortons demain nous allons
devoir habiter chez quelqu'un
cette situation m'angoisse
si mananjary devenues le nouveau
sanctuaire des ong d'autres communes ont
été quasiment oublié nous nous rendons à
nous si valcke à 115 km au nord à cause
de l'état désastreux de la route
aggravée par les deux cyclones il faut
s'y rendre en bateau lors de notre
passage aucune ong présentes ce l'aide
de l'état 23 kg de riz par ménage de
quoi tenir quinze jours la distribution
organisé six jours après le cyclone
dégénèrent en émeutes de la faim
soupçonnant des détournements des
habitants qui le stock depuis cet
épisode marjoline et sa famille n'ont
plus rien reçu seule solution face à la
flambée des prix le système d
j'achète durée à crédit que je revends
un commerçant avec une marge pour
pouvoir rembourser l'emprunt
le message que je lance au gouvernement
c'est que nous avons faim 300 g de riz
coûte 17 centimes d'euro nous avons
mangé à midi mais je ne sais pas si je
vais trouver de quoi manger ce soir
la banque mondiale a pourtant injecté
plus de 36 millions d'euros dans des
programmes d'urgence de son côté l'état
planche toujours sur un programme de
reconstruction des infrastructures très
attendues par les bailleurs
internationaux pour déclencher des aides
supplémentaires en attendant marc jolin
et des centaines de milliers de
sinistrés sont de plus en plus fragilisé
par la précarité climatique